>> Sean: TIME FOR OUR REPORT
HANNITY WATCH ON THE GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
MOMENTS AGO, HOUSE DEMOCRATS
PASSED A PARTIAL SPENDING BILL
WITHOUT ANY FUNDING FOR THE
BORDER WALL THAT THEY SUPPORTED
FUNDING FOR FOUR YEARS AGO.
THE BILL IS, OF COURSE, GOING
NOWHERE IN THE SENATE.
MOMENTS AGO, DUAL ELECTED
SPEAKER PELOSI MADE THIS
CONFESSION.
SHE WOULD GIVE THE PRESIDENT $1
TOWARDS THE WALL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT IS THE SITUATION WHERE
YOU WOULD ACCEPT EVEN A $1 OF
WALL FUNDING TO REOPEN THIS
GOVERNMENT?
>> $1, YEAH, $1.
>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION IS
THE CO-HOST OF THE FIVE, WATTERS
WORLD.
JESSE WATTERS, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, JESSICA WALTERS.
HAPPY NEW YEAR.
NANCY THINKS SHE IS FEELING IT
TODAY, FEELING GREAT.
>> SHE HAD A PRETTY GOOD DAY,
COME ON.
>> Sean: HERE IS THE POINT.
DEMOCRATS SUPPORTED A WALL
BEFORE.
WE HAVE ALL OF THEM SAYING THEY
SUPPORT A WALL, FUNDING A WALL
BUT WE HAVE A DEAD COP.
IT GETS A LITTLE SERIOUS.
WE HAVE OTHER DEAD AMERICANS.
WE HAVE DRUGS, LITERALLY,
TARGETING EVERY TOWN AND EVERY
CITY IN THE COUNTRY CROSSING
THAT BORDER.
WE HAVE HUMAN TRAFFICKING ACROSS
THE BORDER AND TRYSTS THAT WE
HAVE STOPPED CROSSING OUR BORDER
THAT ARE TRYING TO, GANG MEMBERS
TRYING TO CROSS THE BORDER AND
SHE IS TALKING ABOUT $1.
DIRECT YOUR ANSWER TO THE FAMILY
OF OFFICER SINGH WHO DIED THIS
WEEKEND WITH A FIVE-MONTH-OLD
SON AT HOME WHO WAS KILLED BY
SOMEBODY THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED IF THE LAWS WERE OBEYED
AND WE DIDN'T HAVE SANCTUARY
CITIES AND STATES.
TELL THAT FAMILY HOW YOU FEEL
ABOUT THAT REMARK?
>> I FEEL THAT IT IS TERRIBLE.
EVERYONE IN THE COUNTRY.
>> Sean: NANCY'S REMARK IS
TERRIBLE?
>> HAD HE REMARK ABOUT THE $1
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH WHAT
HAPPENED TO OFFICE SEVER SINGH.
>> Sean: SANCTUARY CITIES AND
STATES, THE SHERIFF SAID ON THIS
PROGRAM LAST NIGHT, IN PART
CAUSED WHAT HAPPENED.
WE HAVE THEM IN CUSTODY AND WE
DON'T DEPORT THEM.
THEY ARE AIDING AND ABETTING
LAWBREAKING.
DO YOU SUPPORT THAT?
>> NO BUT I DO SUPPORT A SYSTEM
IN WHICH PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THIS
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY AND THEY BROKE
THE LAW TO GET HERE FEEL THAT
THEY CAN COME OUT AND THEY CAN
WORK WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> Sean: THEY COMMIT MORE
CRIMES.
>> THEY DO NOT COMMIT MORE
>> THE WHOLE THING ABOUT YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A SANCTUARY POLICY,
BECAUSE PEOPLE SNITCH AND YOU
DON'T WANT TO LOCK UP THE
SNITCHERS.
IF YOU DROP A DIME ON ANOTHER
ILLEGAL AND YOU ARE AN ILLEGAL,
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO LOCK YOU
UP BUT LEAVE YOU ALONE.
THE MINUTE SHE GRABBED THE
GAVEL, SHE CAME UNRAVELED.
TRUMP CAME OUT AND STOLE HER
THUNDER AND BASICALLY CALLED HER
A LIAR.
THEY SAY, WALLS DO WORK, NANCY,
EVERYWHERE THEY ARE ERECTED.
>> THE STORY OF TODAY IS NANCY
PELOSI AND NOT DONALD TRUMP.
IT PISSED HIM OFF SHE WAS
GETTING ALL THE ATTENTION.
HE THOUGHT, I'LL WALK DOWN THE
HALLWAY AND TRY TO TAKE THE
ATTENTION.
>> Sean: IS IT TRUE WE HAVE HAD
CRIMINAL ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS THAT
WE HAD IN CUSTODY THAT WEREN'T
HANDED OVER TO ISIS, THE LAW
PROVIDES FOR AND THEY HAVE
KILLED AMERICANS?
>> YES.
>> Sean: AND WE HAVE DRUGS
CROSSING THE BORDER AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS HAPPENING?
>> TERRIBLE THINGS HAPPEN.
>> Sean: GANGS AND TRYS
>> Sean: GANGS AND TERS
>> Sean: GANGS AND TERRORISTS
ARE TRYING TO GET INTO THIS
COUNTRY.
AT WHAT POINT DO THEY TAKE THE
RESPONSIBILITY?
>> THE BORDER ISN'T OPEN.
>> HOW DOES A GUY GET TO
CALIFORNIA AND MURDER THE COP?
>> ARE YOU GUYS KIDDING ME?
YOU ARE MAKING AN ARGUMENT THAT
HOW MANY THOUSANDS OF MILES.
HOW LONG IS THE BORDER, 2500
MILES?
>> Sean: MORE THAN THAT.
>> THAT ENTIRE THING IS OPEN.
>> Sean: NO, IT IS NOT OPEN.
THE PRESIDENT HAS SPEND $3.5
BILLION BUILDING THE WALL.
>> HE IS ALMOST DONE AND HE SAID
HE NEEDED UP $25 MILLION.
HE MAKES UP THE NUMBER AS HE
GOES.
>> Sean: WHEN THE GOVERNMENT,
JESSE, OF THIS COUNTRY,
CONTRIBUTES, AIDS, AND ABETS
LAWBREAKING AND DOESN'T FOLLOW
FEDERAL LAW AND DEPORT PEOPLE
WHO HAVE COMMITTED OTHER CRIMES
BEYOND BEING HERE ILLEGALLY DO
THEY BEAR RESPONSIBILITY?
>> YOU HAVE BLOOD ON YOUR HANDS
IF YOU ARE NOT GOING TO ENFORCE
THE BORDER AND MEN AND WOMEN ARE
DYING IN THIS COUNTRY.
PEL LO
PELOSO
PELOSI TALKS ABOUT COST.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH $5 BILLION
IS OUT OF THE FEDERAL BUDGET.
.1%.
LET ME TRANSLATE FOR NANCY.
SHE SPENT MONEY ON CASH FOR
CLUNKER, SOLYNDRA.
A WALL WORKS.
THE OBAMA WEBSITE THAT COST $1
BILLION DIDN'T.
>> EXCUSE ME.
WE HAD A GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN
WHEN THE REPUBLICANS WERE IN
CHARGE OVER $3.8 BILLION FOR
HEALTH CARE, WHICH EVERY SINGLE
AMERICAN NEEDS.
>> EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN NEEDS
SAFETY TOO.
>> IN 2018, OFF OF THE HEALTH
CARE ISSUE.
>> Sean: OBAMA LOST 69 SEATS,
HOUSE AND SENATE.
TRUMP PICKED UP SENATE SEATS.
>> A BIG ARE PROPORTION OF HOUSE
SEATS THAN THE GOP HAS IN EITHER
OF THOSE ELECTIONS.
>> Sean: YOU DON'T REALLY CARE
ABOUT DACA AND DREAMERS, BECAUSE
TRUMP OFFERED YOU THAT DEAL.
>> TRUMP'S DEAL ALWAYS COMES
WITH THE WALL.